uh will they be telling jimmy garoppolo
to leave san francisco after the season
there's been
some talk about whether or not he'll be
back next year kyle shanahan coach of
the 49ers addressed jimmy garoppolo's
status with the team yesterday here's
shanahan i assume you can't say he's
going to be the starter in 2021 but kind
of how do you view
his future um you know beyond this
season
i mean there's i
i expect jimmy to be our starter next
year i mean i expect him to come and
play with us this year um you know we
have six games left we are not out of
the playoffs yet you know i've been on a
team that was three and six going into a
bye week that ended up winning their
division um i think we have guys on this
team capable of finishing this the right
way we got to do one game at a time and
i hope jimmy can come back and be a part
of that but
to think that we've made any decisions
on anybody going into the future is
isn't the case jimmy's won a lot of
games for us this year it's a lot harder
to win games when he's not here and i'm
just hoping we can get him back
look i don't put a whole lot of stock in
the i expect jimmy to be the starter
next year because he's not going to say
anything other than that now chris the
reality is when the season's over you
don't know what the options are going to
be you don't know who's available right
right it's so premature yeah i expect
them to be the starter next year
whether i
whether that ultimately happens depends
on many factors last year they took a
look at tom brady they decided not to
pursue tom brady there may be others
matt ryan kirk cousins somebody in the
draft if they don't turn the season
around and they're in the top ten
there's too many moving parts here to
say with certainty that garoppolo will
be the quarterback next year well yeah
definitely and and and you know nfl
coaches they're just not like wired to
be thinking of that right now yeah you
could tell like just looking at him
there i haven't talked to kyle in
forever but i know kyle when i see him
pissed off and annoyed and that was kyle
pissed off and annoyed because he
doesn't like you know the status of
their team right now so he's not
thinking about anything in the future as
of right now and when you ask ask him
questions like that i think in this
moment right now he's going well damn i
don't know i mean when jimmy g's there
we win when he's out we can't win so
maybe we freaking need him you know that
that's that's probably really in the
forefront of his brain right now to
where that is a real conversation and
like you said you don't know the grass
isn't always greener on the other side
of the fence so we'll see where it goes
we really will uh and they're not out of
it that's what's crazy too it's banged
up and everything they are
with the fact that so many of those
teams in the nfc west have to play each
other and really a lot of these teams
towards the bottom part of the nfc
playoff standings will play each other
they are they still got a fighting
chance here like a legit fighting chance
they won't need a miracle and i think
because of that he's still going wait i
need jimmy back now because we got a
chance and he gives us a best chance to
win football games and he thinks they
probably could still be dangerous if
they could find a way to get in the
playoffs and be healthy somewhat
and that's right he does give them the
best chance to win because he is
significantly better than nick mullins
or cj
they opted at one point to go with a
less than 100 percent jimmy g
over a 100 percent mullins and beathard
so yeah he gives them the best chance
right now the question is after this
season when you reevaluate and every
season of every nfl team is a kind of
its own
contained
universe now and
a lot can change from one year to the
next and you you don't even begin
to analyze how those pieces are going to
fit together until your season is over
and and
hey if they would somehow run the table
which is not going to be easy to do
10 and six does that get them in i don't
know this year maybe it doesn't yeah it
might not but they're still not out of
it they're still not out of it and until
you're out of it you don't throw in the
towel i can't imagine any coach would
would do that and i
what i know of kyle that's the last
thing he would do is give up prematurely
on a season no definitely not yeah
there's too much you know fight in that
coaching staff in general and and the
jimmy g thing i think you know again
it's it's still to be evaluated and like
you said it's going to be one of those
things that it's going to basically come
down to the season's over and now we
self-scout ourselves as a football team
and we go over every player and really
go okay this is what he did good blah
blah blah oh we wish he would have been
better in this area and
then you start to go how do i feel about
him as our guy at that position and
they're going to do that for every
position
let alone when they have that
conversation take into account who is
out there that's available on their
scouting board free agents maybe trade
possibilities all those things and
that's when those conversations happen
but that'll be
not till two three weeks after your
football season is completely done to
where they start to try to figure those
things out
yeah and we'll see how that all plays
out for the 49ers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports